right right now you're probably stressed
at least a little bit and that's because
it's that time again when there is a
tremendous amount of pressure on you to
buy just the right thing for a whole
bunch of different friends and family
members it's a good problem to have but
it's a stressful one fortunately it's
also that time when wired puts out its
annual wishlist we've got all the goods
on that list and I happen to have some
of them with me today here in studio to
give you gift ideas so if you're looking
for something big or small or luxurious
or relatively inexpensive we've got you
covered let's take a look let's start
with the small stuff first tile if you
know somebody who loses things a lot
this $35 little dongle will give them
incredible peace of mind you can attach
it to anything you lose a lot basically
your keys your wallet your dog your mind
whatever and you can track where the
object is in the app you can also hit
the fine button in the app and this will
chirp to let you know where the object
is for this year's wish list we
specifically mentioned tile Pro which is
an updated version of tile it has an
extended range of up to 300 feet and
because it runs on a coin cell battery
it should last for about a year also in
the category of small but infinitely
useful is the Apple watch the Apple
watch comes with one big caveat the
person who you buy it for has to have an
iPhone it's also expensive this is the
Apple watch series for which starts at
399 but what better way to worm your way
into somebody's heart than to tell them
they have in a regular harpy am i right
now maybe you're not sure if the person
you're buying for even wants an Apple
watch and that's a valid concern most
people with smartphones do need
headphones at some point and our advice
if you're buying for the audiophile in
your life just to skip the air pods and
go with these instead these are wireless
earbuds from master and dynamic they are
fancy looking and fabulous sounding now
at $299 they are a little bit more
expensive than what you would pay for
wireless earbuds from pretty much
everybody else Apple Sony jaybird but
these look a lot better
you're looking for something less
expensive something that still fits in
the stocking you might want to consider
this this is a natto knife it's $12 and
it comes from a factory near Kyoto Japan
that is known for making chisels knives
that are used in school woodshop so
you're not gonna do any serious carving
with this thing but you might use it to
open envelopes or Amazon boxes or
Simmonds
just don't try to take it on a plane and
maybe don't give it to someone right
when things are heating up at the dinner
table around the holidays because
politics maybe you're looking for
something a little more creative
my favorite creative gift on this year's
wish list was made for Instagram except
it doesn't even share to Instagram which
is great
it's the teal lomography sprocket rocket
this is a $69 funky looking camera that
takes panoramic photos across multiple
frames of thirty-five millimeter film
and the end result has sprocket holes
pretty cool if you have small children
and you are self punishing enough to
want to welcome more noise into your
home and you're gonna want to check this
thing out this is the blip blocks it
costs $189 it's really fun
and it's designed for kids ages 3 and up
but honestly you're probably gonna end
up playing with it yourself after the
kids go to bed don't say we didn't warn
if you're really looking to impress
someone I would get them this Eames
radio there are fewer than a thousand of
these made which means that the number
on the price tag for this thing is
higher in the number of units available
I'm gonna let you do the math on that
but this is a revived version of the
1946 tabletop radio that Ames made and
to catch up with modern times it now
works with Bluetooth but maybe you're
feeling over the usual gadget tree and
who can blame you there's a lot of junk
out there if you want to buy something
you can actually feel good about well
this year on Wired's wishlist we have
more than a few eco-friendly products so
I'm going to take you through some of
them now and we're gonna start
with poor office you might know Rafi's
for their flats this year they started
making these slip-on sneakers the
company uses a proprietary yarn that's
made from the plastic from recycled
water bottles these are machine washable
they are extremely comfortable and they
cost one hundred and twenty-five dollars
which is not cheap but hey it's a small
price to pay for the comfort of your
feet if the person you're buying for
happens to be a surfer and you're gonna
want to check this out one of the things
you might know about surfers is that
they tend to care a lot about the ocean
but a lot of the materials that go into
surfing equipment generally aren't that
eco-friendly which is why we love the
firewire eco board it costs seven
hundred and sixty-five dollars the
makers of this to finfish have taken
steps to manufacture the board in a way
that's ecologically responsible they're
using a plant based resin which is
better than the synthetic stuff is
usually full of nasty chemicals and the
factories that the components come from
have been audited to ensure that they're
not dumping toxins into the atmosphere
or the waterways let's say you don't
want to buy somebody shoes and you
definitely don't know anybody who needs
a surfboard I bet you know somebody
who's cracked their phone if they
haven't they're probably going to
because phones are slippery little
suckers right that's where the iFixit
pro tech tool kit comes in for $60 you
can get somebody all the tools they need
to fix their own gadgets which means
they don't have to run out and buy new
stuff all the time it can just fix their
own phone and glass not included and you
might void your warranty but you know
what sometimes DIY is just the better
way to go okay but about that stress
thing I mentioned earlier it's a real
thing so why not give somebody the
ability to just kick back have a strong
drink and scroll mindlessly on their
phone for hours and hours without
worrying that the battery is going to
die that's why on our wish list this
year we have things like this $60 nimble
charger which charges your phone and we
also have this $50 Norlin rock tumbler
that's $50 for a single glass I asked
about it too but this is like really
really nice glass and this is like you
can see the future here this thing and
finally on our wish list we also have
this 24 dollar bottle of wonderment
schnapps look who yes we put snaps on
our wish list I think this gives me a
unique insight into my editors mind and
for journalism with a capital J I
suppose I should try it honestly it
smells like mouthwash I don't have high
expectations so yeah like I said this is
this is it this is the holidays when
things stress you out just kick back
scroll on your phone have a drink and
try to be as merry as possible for more
gift ideas you can go to Wired's wish
list online go to wire comm I'm Lauren
go for Wired thank you for watching and
Happy Holidays
[Music]